je pensais d'eux les policiers ont eu
peur je vois les il est ici mais oui je
vois mal des policiers le matin se lever
en disant tiens je vais briser ma
carrière et je vais taper un type noire
de surcroît comme ça ça va faire une
belle émotion
ça va être formidable non et je déteste
c'est ce lynchage de trois pauvres
garçons qui doivent être effondré
aujourd'hui kim et perdent leur boulot
qui vont être condamnés qui ont été
lynchés par par tous les réseaux sociaux
et par la france entière par le
président de la république lui-même
je pense que là moi je ne participerai
pas à cette opération
alors trois pauvres garçons qui perdent
leur métier êtes vous choqué par les
propos d'eric zemmour sur la terre
michel oui non alors question ou une
avancée alors déjà vous raphaël
stainville que vous êtes choqués par les
propos d'eric zemmour
bah ça dépend si on les isole ou si on
les place dans ce contexte difficile la
première chose pour répondre à votre
question la domaine est la manière la
plus honnête possible
je pense qu'à une question qui est
implicite c'est dès lors que eric
zemmour parle
la question c'est vous pour ou contre
eric zemmour est donc j'aurais tendance
à dire par honnêteté d'abord que j'ai
tendance à le soutenir de manière très
générale et la deuxième question est la
deuxième réponse que j'apporte c'est un
deuxième wii c'est que aujourd'hui on
voit très bien la manière dont était
instrumentaliser cette affaire hier que
moi je suis bien évidemment comme tous
les millions de français qui ont vu les
images de cette de cette agression
de ce producteur on ne peut être que
orthez effectivement les images sont
accablantes
mais on a une vidéo on n'a pas le son on
n'a pas le contexte on n'a pas l'hyper
contexte est donc déjà il ya un problème
c'est qu'avant même de dalé qui a une
enquête qui soit plus poussée on est
déjà en train de les condamner et
l'opinion publique les a condamnés donc
moi je pense que il ya d'abord une
présomption d'innocence quand bien même
ce que l'on voit à l'image est
absolument audio après les tentatives
d'explication et de d'eric zemmour soit
pour rappeler le passé du producteur
soit pour immédiatement expliquer le
malaise finalement de la police parce
que c'est ces policiers ces trois
policiers
alors selon les rapports qui est qui
commencent à circuler
ils étaient pour la plupart très bien
noté donc comment on essaye d'expliquer
ce geste incompréhensible insupportable
ce que vous avez une version des faits
vous qui vous est arrivé non aujourd'hui
je mens et très parcellaires et c'est ça
en fait ce qui est compliqué c'est que
la société médiatique veut que l'on juge
sur des images immédiatement sans
arrière pensée sans recul et donc ça moi
ça me gêne d'abord spontanément benjamin
vous avez fait c'est que il est très
malin et moi effectivement le choix des
mots dans sa bouche c'est toujours très
précis il emploie ses trois pauvres
garçons on peut pas dire ça il peut dire
la même chose sont son centre sans dire
c'est trop beau garçon ce qu'on a vu là
et honnêtement on évite les caméras à
l'extérieur voit pas très bien ce qui
pourrait sauver ses élus mais et l'étude
et le probable
en faisant ça qu'est ce qu'il fait il
provoque une fois de plus et fait que ça
même sur le fond peut-être qu'on peut
effectivement dire oui une présence
d'innocence mais il va quand même loin
dans les mots 3 pour garçons je délègue
un mec qui s'est fait tabasser devant
les caméras on y peut tout dire sauf ça
un état grave oui c'est bien ça
compliqué même si de rien et juger et
rien n'est fait trois pauvres garçons
non c'est moi là guillaume genton moi je
pense que c'est son rôle à eric zemmour
de poser toutes les questions que tout
le monde se pose tous se posent tout bas
mais michele épouse tooba ce que n'a pas
beaucoup s'il ya plein de gens le
monsieur a raison je trouve que tout le
monde a jugé très très rapidement cette
affaire même si les images sont là et
sont choquantes et ce qu'a subi michel
c'est absolument inacceptable
mais je pense qu'un petit écho à la
sphère georgetown aux états unis où on a
mis du temps à réagir il s'est fait
tabasser et je pense que c'est normal qu
eric zemmour interroge chanceux le fait
que avec une vidéo
qui certes dure 12 minutes mais on n'est
jugé immédiatement la faire sans son
sans savoir ce qui s'est passé alors
depuis il ya eu des témoignages
l'enquète avance les gens vont être
condamnés est en tout cas c'est
condamnable ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
normal mais c'est son rôle de polémiste
eric zemmour et franchement ça m'aurait
étonné qu'ils fassent le contraire qui
soutiennent michel aulas nicolas c'est
ce qu'ils disent et un polémiste c'est
pas un animateur
donc à un moment donné il a un point de
vue il faut plus grand showman
maintenant les attendait son avis à tous
coups mais non mais il ya eu moi je suis
pas pour ou contre zemmour âge - il ya
un point de vue qui a été notre point de
vue par rapport à des images et par
rapport à un invité et on a cette vision
et lui il a une autre vision qui est la
vision vu des policiers notamment donné
il faut l'accepter il faut aujourd'hui
qui est du débat à la télévision
il n'y a plus de débat la télévision on
peut plus parler on est pour ou contre
c'est ce que vous avez des mesures et on
est des pros contre les bourreaux contre
la police et si surpris aujourd'hui si
cette mise à bas de la rue monte les
gens montent parce qu'à un moment donné
on se range d'un côté ou de l'autre mais
ça naît ça ne peut pas marcher comme ça
il faut que les gens ils puissent
débattre il peut il faut que les gens
puissent ne pas être d'accord on peut
pas continuer à voir cette société de2
tribunal populaire qui est pour ou
contre quelque chose je trouve ça
ridicule et dangereux
géraldine sauf que monsieur eric zemmour
a rappelé le casier judiciaire de michel
mais il aurait pu aussi rappelé son
propre moi la judiciaire illzach il a
été condamné
effectivement mois globalement je ne
suis jamais d'accord avec zemmour je
trouve que souvent ces propos sont
abjects et ses dérapages sont immondes
pour autant l'émission j'ai regardé de
bout en bout
et effectivement je trouve que c'est un
peu malhonnête intellectuellement parce
que d'abord il dit que globalement
évidemment il soutient la police
nationale et qui condamne évidemment les
gestes ces trois de ces trois policiers
ça c'est la première chose ensuite ils
rappellent effectivement le cv et le
casier de michel et marc menant leur
prend tout de suite en dix ans mais
c'est pas parce qu'il a un casier qu'on
doit le tabasser il dit mais oui marc
maintenant vous avez raison bien
évidemment donc attention aussi aux
raccourcis parce que il a globalement
moi je trouve tout le temps tort mais là
en particulier et alors nous quand on
part ici dans tpm b par exemple on dit
on pense aux gens en prison
on pense à eux ils nous regardent
beaucoup ils ont besoin de notre
émission c'est un divertissement pense à
eux
est ce qu'on pense aussi aux victimes de
ceux qui sont en prison donc attention
quand il dit les ponts garçons ça peut
être aussi des pauvres garçons au centre
bell et pauvres games ont ils vont aller
en taule ce sera peut-être bien fait
pour eux parce qu'ils l'ont mérité au vu
de ce qu'ils ont fait à michel mais
attention à des raccourcis aussi un peu
un peu facile en rouge le chantier du
pays
alors oui effectivement
parce qu'il parle surtout aussi de
jeunes perdreaux il rappelle
effectivement ses antécédents c'est tout
ce qu'on craignait
et puis est ce qui me gêne c'est
d'utiliser le mot lyncher en parlant des
policiers qui ont été lynchées qui
regarde la vidéo le lynchage ou
quelqu'un se fait tabasser se sont pas
les policiers et médiatiquement ces
monopoles médiatiques mais tout mais
tout n'est pas que ça me parler de ce
qui s'est passé samedi il dit trois
policiers qui se sont fait lyncher
donc au bout d'un moment qu'il utilise
lui aussi bien les mots lui qui les
connaît tellement bien et qu'on regarde
encore la vidéo ou alors qu'il utilise
et estaires lynchage médiatique qui sont
faits les laisser dans la rue si bon on
va pas revenir dessus mais c'est faux
policiers nous fait lyncher
kelly bah moi malheureusement c'est bête
et méchant mais je crois ce que je vois
et dans tous les cas quand je vois une
vidéo comme ça j'ai vraiment du mal à
entendre ce type de propos pour moi
c'est je ne peux pas longtemps que je
suis désolé qu'on compte on voit la
vidéo on peut pas se dire c'est pauvre
gars ces pauvres types qui ne l'est pas
voilà je croyais à un moment donné où je
sais pas
c'est ça le fait est que une image
chanson s'en [ __ ] si certains gamins
capacit en mai mais pas réfléchi pas
réfléchir avec ses images à tous en même
temps on ne peut pas réfléchir à ces
images sans contexte c'est bien
évidemment tout le monde sera d'accord
pour dire que c'est ignoble abeilles
mais on ne peut pas réfléchir si on à
caussens sûr qu'on a eu cette
explication
ouais mais pour moi quand bien même le
couple un essai sur le domaine des
habitants mais ce genre de scènes un peu
de complexité
mais la complexité mais à un moment
donné quand on a 12 minutes d'image
c'est compliqué pour nous de se dire
mais ça n'est pas aussi chaud quand ils
sont graves mais je veux dire été démis
de leurs fonctions et c'est très bien de
quoi il
mais c'est pas ça ne devrait pas exister
il ne s'est pas légal ce qu'ils ont fait
donc dans tous les cas on ne devrait pas
se poser la moindre question c'est
condamnable m voulait céder condamné
avant même que l'enquêté qui condamne à
bernard montiel le plus difficile dans
cette histoire c'est la récupération
politique qui est faite de cette affaire
et ça c'est tout le monde s'en mêle
évidemment la droite donc valeurs
actuelles
je suis invité j'ai pas demandé à
participer je suis content de l'endroit
de pouvoir répondre aux normes
américaines très à droite c'est pas très
adroite maladroit emmanuel bach mois
fait la valeur de 10 par là où je
voulais dire donc sans mais c'est pas la
peine de deux états mais j'attaque pas
ce monsieur mais non il y obtient
problème je dis qu'après vient des visio
j'avais d'inviter une récupération
politique est ce trop ça traduit surtout
un malaise dans le monde de la police
ils sont fatigués ils ont peuvent plus
les mecs ça fait des années bien que
qu'il ya des problèmes en france ils
sont sur le terrain tout le temps ils
sont maltraités
voyez mammifères moi j'ai dit le mot de
bâtard vous m me moquer qui mène son
récit comme ça mais rappelez-vous hier
avec madame chapa je vous écoute très
peu j'ai dit les les trois bâtard mais
je regrette ce mot là bien sûr parce que
bâtard c'est un mot qu'on utilise assez
facilement et ce que vous avez dit ça
les polices sur les platines et oui j'ai
dit hier y en a qu'un qui me l'a relevé
le seuil qu'il avait raison il se
déguise sur internet my quelque chose
d'accord il a bien raison c'est un fils
qui la verrait pas 6 2 si vous devez
relever toutes les conneries ce qui n'a
pas relevé c'est que j'ai dit que
j'aimais la police et que je la
soutenait à fond ça il n'a pas relevé
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que ça
traduit le malaise de la police il ya un
vrai malaise dans la police il faut s'en
occuper
il faut les aimer il faut arrêter de
penser qu'ils ont tous d'aider des gens
pas bien ce sont les gens font très bien
passée à lyon
ce qu'a dit michel et ses plages débat
il a raison la série pouvait démontrer
moore on est là dessus isabelle qu'on a
promis letizi match entièrement sans la
même ligne que géraldine est en revanche
je suis d'accord avec machin mais que de
toute façon dans tous les cas de figure
le monde sur les profs garsik à dire
quels sont à proscrire parce qu'ils sont
terriblement maladroit mais quand on
regarde effectivement la totalité de la
séquence se semble ce sont deux choses
de choses différentes et effectivement
c'est un polémiste on peut on a
parfaitement le droit de ne pas être
d'accord avec ce qu'il dit mais en
revanche il faut regarder la séquence
complète et pas jugé bon goût il n'a pas
dérapé donc s'inscrire dans un contexte
explosif
il a encore distiller des idées qui vont
parapher relancer le débat et la baisse
plus il va ainsi les données dans le
doute oui oui en même temps qu'à toi ne
reprennent que cette phrase les
conclusions à partir de cette vidéo est
de dire que là qu'il ya une violence
systémique dans la police que la police
elle même chose et je vous dis la grande
force sinon il prend un fait un fait
majeur il fait la syntaxe de la
rhétorique il est très bon là dedans
donc partie de ces trois pauvres gars il
sait très bien ce qu'il dit c'est plein
ce qu'il fait il va mettre le doute il
va s'il va distiller un doute et pour le
coup ils sont pas jugés mais c'est
maladroit effectivement ça fout plus le
bordel je suis je trouve qu'il ne fait
pas du bien à la police parce que ça
voudrait mettre bien sûr les policiers
sur ces trois mois ça fait même et sa
mêlée tous les pc au même niveau
or moi je ne mets pas au même niveau ces
trois types là qui visiblement ne ne
devrait pas porter l'uniforme et les
policiers qui eux se retrouve par
exemple vers l'asie fait station guy à
ce moment là effectivement eux peuvent
ressentir la peur est effectivement eux
peuvent à ce moment là à voir des gestes
qu'ils allaient riz c'est souvent les
mêmes circuler même qui était une
manifestation dans le cas d'un service
de maintien de l'ordre
le lendemain matin on leur demande de
mettre des amendes pour les masquer le
surlendemain se disent voir le soir même
ils sont sur une autre intervention leur
mission même si c'est ça je sais plus
qui poser cette question la question du
sens des missions la police elle est
importante
et aujourd'hui on les utilise la plupart
du temps pour faire de la merde et donc
bien évidemment que ça ça provoque je
suis pas en train de d'excusés cet acte
inexcusable mais on leur fait faire
n'importe quoi
et donc il faut comprendre aussi la
détresse de ces gens là celui de la même
chose dans les envois là effectivement
c'est pas c'est pas un exemple flagrant
et nous ne tirons pas des conclusions il
dit pas ça il va après des mots
particuliers une fois de plus il veut
dire voilà attendons quelques choses
soient réglées
qu'est-ce que j'ai une ascension débat
ça c'est autre chose est sûre
l'instrumentalisation qui est fait
la récupération qui est fait par un
certain nombre de mouvements
pauli tirent sûr